let don't do this for the camera don't
do this for the for the high-g likes
let's get this right
[Music]
my name is Chris I'm Blake
hey I'm Jessica and I'm Tyler and today
we're identifying Central and South
American countries okay you're gonna
know this right cuz I promise you I got
D's in all of this in school I don't
know if we're comfortable with this map
I don't know me but that is no I don't
think anybody knows what that is you
know what at first I was gonna be happy
with 75% but the other guys just talk
trash to us when we got here and now I'm
feeling very good yeah we're going for
like a hundred at least I was pretty
chill but they just lit a fire we're
ready to take this check it started yeah
let's go do it
ten minutes on the clock starting now
alright okay no all right so this is
obviously Mexico Mexico we got that one
we put that um Brazil Brazil right
mm-hmm all right that's the biggest
country in South America right yeah
that's the easy ones we already said
Argentina right yes I know this is
chilly cuz it looks like Chile and this
is Brazil it's huge then Venezuela right
there I know this is Colombia I know
this is rude why cuz I know they've like
they're competitive when it comes to
Miss Universe and this makes sense at
the right by each other we're talking
about the ones that I can't pronounce
so this is Suriname Surinam sorry mom I
know that Paraguay is right above Buble
oh this is Bolivia because there's like
two bees so Panama Panama Panama right
there and this is Peru right there's
like Guiana and French Guiana but I
don't remember this one French this is
this is French yeah cuz I was just
trying to figure that out but the ones
with an i though that don't worry
we don't need that's not important yeah
why and then this is a dried herb yeah
that's it
that's Ecuador okay cool yeah
I'm not sure if I'm saying it right I've
been here Belize the way that I remember
this is Guatemala is that it kind of
looks like a backwards Jeep it's oh my
god it does what's right here what is
this that is which are just second for
that one it doesn't think I mean that's
what you remember things you like
mnemonics and all that stuff and this
one is El Salvador what's just know
what's in here so what are the Central
American countries
I thought Colombia was in there but
usage way of knowing what country this
is but the way I was like I know honey
like Honduras okay I mean that works it
works it's gonna get us the Honduras at
the Honduras is right over hyung do yeah
so there's what Amala and the
Guatemala's right here
that's that I'm pretty I'm 100 percent
I'm 100 percent we could give
Guatemala's here okay these are this is
this is pretty cool right cuz I think
water mala is right and then next Mexico
I'm pretty sure now you got me
questioning myself man Haiti and the
Dominican Republic as far as the debate
if we're doing the I if we're do if you
know what it is you're a hundred percent
then we're doing those not like those
points this one is the Bahamas if it's a
bunch of islands and the Bahamas ends
with that yeah okay
this right here Jamaica Jamaica that's
to make up was right here
that's Haiti Haiti don't get mad at me
I know Brianna's from here somewhere
then what's worse before Rico I believe
where no Rico they're called a sit-up
thing like the blanks that's sounds like
a good bad because have no music US
Virgin Islands are right here and then
the British Virgin Islands these
countries are like water loops and kits
all kinds of sipping Caribbean violence
they're all different countries don't
world in one country yeah they will get
mad yeah they're all different but we're
gonna skip it because we don't know SAT
rules I know there's something called
the Falcon Islands but I know if it's
this one oh this one's Galapagos right
is it yep wait no wait that's Africa
isn't it I don't know so we got to
figure out which one is Guatemala and
which one is never agua hmm I think that
this is Guatemala ok Go's because that
one the the researcher he went off of
Ecuador right okay I don't think I
really can know like
that kind that was really bad but I mean
it's close enough oh my god what are we
miss why am i blanking on that country's
new Nicaragua okay stop it
this maps homophobic I know it is let
don't do this for the camera don't do
this for the for the IG likes let's get
this right
how many minutes are left we have time
to tangent yeah I think so on his hand
oh yeah you're putting this on all right
we gotta do it now
let's do Guatemala Nicaragua Guatemala
Nicaragua all right let's go what
all right darn it there's like a bunch
of here it's like Oh
nice yeah I think we did great I think
the next time Buzzbee should come with a
heart or quiz I think so too
and we hear that this just goes to show
you don't need to be 6 feet tall
geography
[Music]